i just sometimes think about something
i'm like yeah we should do it let's do
partnership with that company in that
company and people in the office are
like
yeah you're credited they would never
play along and i'm like why not and
then we make it happen welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley and is sponsored by leumitech
hippo insurance
touring upwards labs and hillel at
stanford this one is all about buying
online and we love buying online
meet along gum zoo the ceo of round
forest alone is co-founder and ceo of
ron forest a global leader in the
shopping recommendation space
and an angel investor round forest's
mission is to simplify shopping by
helping consumers make better and
quicker purchases
and ultimately buy with confidence over
40 million shoppers rely on ronford's
tools for buying advice every month
alon founded brown forest after working
at google and before that at intel's
machine learning team
he holds a bsc in engineering from ben
gurion university
along gamzo thank you for joining me
today how are you i'm great michael
thank you for having me
it's it's an honor having you here uh
you know we we look similar and i think
and i'm taking that as you know a vote
of confidence because
i don't know what my girlfriend thinks
about what i'm wearing but as long as
you're wearing what i'm wearing i think
that i'm okay
alone i've been following your journey
for for quite some time i we we got to
know each other a little bit
back in palo alto when i visited you and
i think that what you're doing with ron
forest
it's both incredibly innovative but i
but i love how you're looking at a
you know a market that has been
disrupted you know a
couple of few times over in these last
decade and
really rethinking the way we shop with
confidence and but before we get to all
that alone
how does a founder of a startup have
time to do gardening
during covet how does that work well
actually
during covet it's maybe the the easiest
because you
you just stuck at home anyway i just
feel lucky
i have some room for for that gardening
uh i love that and what do you grow
uh like all sort of stuff i think what
i'm most proud of is my
tea and herb spot i have like
mint and all sort of other stuff which i
have no idea how to say in english but
all different types of herbs
and my other hobbies just to make
tea and drink out of it so and now that
i know that you are my neighbor you are
you are welcome to
to drop by for a cup of tea i love it
alone
your journey is sort of like you know
the classical the classic journey that
any investor would want in a founder
right
you know ben gurion university to intel
machine learning
google on strategy and expansion and
working with startups
and now round forest and and i have to
sort of
hear from you about your journey did you
know you're going to be an entrepreneur
later on
when you joined intel because you worked
at two very large corporations you know
living the good life and then you drop
everything to go and create an early
stage startup so
walk me a little bit through the journey
that you've had yeah
sure so i think uh on one hand
i definitely always knew that
entrepreneurship
is where i'm at at but
that the path that i took was entirely
random and
looking back saying what we are doing
today i think uh
the background the specific background i
had at intel
and at google really led me uh to
realizing the problem well
trying to solve today and to equip me
with
the the kind of knowledge that i need in
order to write
to do that but it's almost very random i
i definitely
didn't plan it i think choosing where i
went to school was
the most random decision it was like
i just needed to sign up for some
some class because i wanted to get a
visa to the us
and i i need like a university approval
and i just signed up for something my
friend
sign up both for the faculty and also um
for the
for the unit specific university for ben
gurion
just like one of my pals back then told
me come it's going to be fun and i'm
like yeah sure sounds like fun
uh same as the intel it was like the
most random
job posting that i just joined when i
was still in university
i mean also google i just joined because
a good friend of mine that i was
traveling with
when i was like traveling to india uh
was at the team there and uh
and i had entirely different plan and
she told me
you should check it out i think you will
find it interesting so it all
was very random i love that i love that
randomness and and
seeing what you're doing today i think
you know what i've been hearing through
this show is that a lot of people are
looking back and they're saying yeah
it's very you know i started this
episode by saying you know it's very
easy to connect the dots it's classic
you know
you just go to ben gurion you go to
intel you go to google and then you
create a startup but
you know but then all when you dissect
each component individually you
understand that it is random and
and it is more about this
entrepreneurial mindset of of you know
of harnessing this randomness and
enjoying the opportunities presented to
you
that i think is the most inspiring part
alone before you tell me about ron
forest i want you to share with me
about the industry you chose to go into
you know it's a massive you know
horrible
and very competitive industry uh give me
a little bit of insight
why did you choose e-commerce and you
know reviews and customer
confidence yeah so
definitely perhaps one of the biggest
multi-trillion industries
out there and i think as much as it's
big and there's so much innovation and
companies there
from us for us from the consumer point
of view
still it can be very difficult
and confusing sometimes when you just
want to
buy something you just want to get a new
laptop you want to get a tv
and and you are bombarded with all those
different
models and informations and reviews and
expert reviews
so surprisingly as much as this industry
continue to
progress and grow it's just becoming
more and more difficult
and right i think we realize that that's
the problem
we want to solve making this decision uh
process much simpler and easier
mainly because of the dispatch that we
discussed before
i think when i was at google and i kind
of got
a great overview of the internet and all
the different business models and all
the different
companies that are innovating there uh
i think and and coming with the
background i had
uh from intel of uh machine learning and
the
and the the kind of value that you can
drive
leveraging this kind of uh technology we
just
were looking for an industry that is
that has that complexity that has
so much data so much information that
the only way that you can
drive value for consumers is by
adopting and using this kind of approach
and i think that kind of what led us to
to solving that problem i think what's
what's fascinating about e-commerce
is that there's so many players right
you know even
the biggest fish in e-commerce is a tiny
tiny fish in a huge huge pond
where you have you know millions of
sellers you have billions of buyers and
and it's this huge marketplace and one
of the one of the statistics that i was
shocked by recently
was that actually most of the reviews
that we're seeing aren't necessarily
truthful reviews like i remember
you know i remember from time to time i
used to buy something from amazon and
get this gift card that says you know
what if you
read us a review we'll send you a free
whatever right
and but i didn't really understand how
how you know
convoluted this market is and and it
makes sense when you think about it that
there are so many different interests
that are aligned right i mean one
person's success
does mean another person's demise in a
lot of ways in e-commerce and so
coming in as a third party and trying to
sort of democratize and level the
playing field and provide that
you know equally equal equilibrium for
the customer i think that's i think
that's fantastic what are the biggest
you know challenges as you go into
thinking about this industry and you're
thinking about
you know making the decision process
easy for customers
tell me a little bit about the customer
experience and and how you
think about you know this 21st century
or 2021
millennial consumer that goes to buy
yeah
definitely i i think uh
perhaps our biggest challenge is finding
this perfect balance
between just like so much information
and so many
so many insight and uh
and data that we can show to our user uh
and
consumers and on the other end people
want like uh and this is our mission to
simplify the process
and right and kind of help you to make a
decision which is
fast you don't you don't want to read
too much
information you don't want to look on so
many products and and finding this
perfect balance between
helping you to be informed enough and
understand how this recommendation
is uh created and why you should trust
it
uh and finding this perfect balance this
i think that's always
kind of the theme of our challenge in
any kind of new solution new tool new
angle that we are developing
right and and you one of the ways that
you go about this whole thing is
that you're actually you know scanning
millions of products right and you have
also millions of of people using you so
can you share with me more tangibly what
is actually round forest and how are you
actually helping you know people make
purchasing decisions easier
yeah definitely so we have a
few tools each one is a different
experience and and solve
kind of a different uh
need of the user well everything we do
is a b2c
it's a direct to consumers we have more
than 40 million users
that are coming and using our tools
before making a
decision um i think the main
kind of differentiator and edge and
unique approach that we are bringing to
that space
of the shopping recommendation which is
a huge space
is the more technology-driven approach
if you think about the more
traditional players in that space uh
consumer reports
which is basically been there forever
and used to be
like a print uh and it's it's still
actually a print that people get
delivered to their home every day
uh and wildcat wildcatter and finnett
and some other well-known brands um all
of them are very
uh manual and they have expert and it's
valuable
it has its own value for for the users
but it's also
limited in their capacity of the amount
of user
of product they can check the amount of
amount of information
they can look into how updated they can
be and what we are bringing
into this world is technology is the
ability to collect all the data that is
already available out there
and analyze that and come with insights
which are basically what you would you
would have done if you had like
endless time to go over all that
information so we want to save you that
time
and give you those uh curated insights
right but part you know on the other
double edge sort of of giving curated
insights in an industry like e-commerce
is that you have
you know for every search term that i
could think of even you know any camera
term or whatever
you know there's millions of different
decision points right and and
every and part of the goal of every
seller is to make their product
personalized for you while they're
trying to personalize it for a million
people
so how do you as round force come and
tackle some of the biases that i as a
consumer
can't ignore because i am an irrational
decision maker right i
i will choose the more expensive bottle
of wine just because
it's more expensive it's not necessarily
the right one for me as would probably
be advised by runforce so how do you
actually go and
sort of disconnect those biases through
your platform
great and i think you just touched on
our product vision uh
kind of the pet we are going is to be
able to provide
more and more personalized
recommendation uh
i think no one no one today uh in the
internet
gives you a recommendation that really
knows you
uh right um and and that's exactly what
we are trying to figure out
what kind of questions what are the
right questions we need to ask you
and now we can learn more about you from
your past
interactions with our recommendation so
we could provide you uh the product that
is really right for you is right from
michael
because there is no one best product
right uh
for everyone and i think right and i
think what you're saying
what you're saying is that there are you
know the marketplace like any commerce
you do have two sides here you have
you first have to really really know the
products and then you have to really
really know the customer so it sounds to
me like right now the focus is more
understanding okay scanning those
millions of products you're already
providing great value to the 40 million
customers
a month but then by knowing both the
products really well and knowing the
customers really well
then you're able to really do this
integration definitely i think it's a
nice way to look at that
we we know the the market very well
and now we want to know you better so we
can give you a better recommendation
and we also want to give you like you're
going to make this investment
you're going to answer a question you're
going to provide us
information about yourself only if you
will have the right incentive only if
you
if it will be wolfie that's exactly
that's exactly our product vision and
those are the things we are
experimenting today
to figure out the exact experience that
will be useful enough and will help you
uh to get the product that is right for
you i love that so
you know the whole process is all about
figuring out everyday different
challenges and
and i'd love to get into you know your
mind a little bit as
the founder of of an early stage startup
here you have to reinventing yourself
the company the culture constantly
i'm gonna i'm very excited to experience
you know being an early stage founder
myself sooner rather than later
what are some of the most exhilarating
things that you've experienced
during the lifetime of run force until
today that you're saying like wow if i
could just
talk to myself you know a few years ago
like look like
get excited alone because these are
what's gonna happen
definitely definitely and when you
decide to do this let me know uh
and but uh uh definitely i think there's
like so many
lessons i can share but um
i think what what i it is from our
own personal uh path the the one thing
i'm most
passionate about and been learning the
most from my personal experience and
from reading and talking with others
is a company culture and
and i think that's by itself like uh our
all uh topic uh
but i think that uh what the the kind of
uh uh involvement we did
throughout the year the landforest exist
for uh
more than six years now right almost
seven years yeah
and and when we started we were very
inexperienced
uh as a founder me and my co-founder we
were like 28
and and we didn't know that much about
building a company and we
actually didn't know that much about
even a product we came
from a very uh acquisition and growth
uh background and i think that the thing
that we learned the most
along the way is how to build uh a
company culture that
can scale and how to put and i think the
one thing that that we learned that is
most important and it wasn't that
obvious obvious to us in the beginning
is the most important thing is to put
the consumer
always in the middle in the center of
your focus
and i think if initially we were very
focused about growth
which was useful what it would help us
to grow to our side especially as we are
as we were bootstrapped
and we added we needed to find like a
way to finance
our growth uh but at certain point if we
really wanted
to make a difference if we really wanted
to put to build
a company culture that could scale
we needed to do that shift into putting
the the user
in in the middle and speaking with our
consumer users and consumers
all that all the time and really
focusing first
and foremost about solving their problem
and you touched on that a little bit but
it's very irregular
to go almost five years right i mean i
remember reading an article i guess it
was
oh i can't believe it was a year and a
half ago you know boots trapping a
company for five years without raising a
single dime
and you know i'm now that i'm saying you
know every every entrepreneur
or somebody who wants to be an
entrepreneur the very first question is
okay when can i raise my precede okay
when can i raise my
my seat and then series et cetera you're
an angel investor yourself i'm very
lucky to be
in a to be working with you on a
specific thing but
that's very different culture than what
we're experiencing in our day-to-day
life
right in our community in our ecosystem
both in israel and the area
what made you decide to go the
bootstrapped way yeah
so so i think initially we we just
didn't
thought about it we we just like okay we
we understand the problem we had the
skills we needed in order to
to create an mvp and we just did it um
and i think since then we were just
focusing on
on an mvp and and since then until today
our growth was never
limited by by the need of external
funding
which i think is we are very lucky uh
yeah of course it's definitely not
something you can take for any industry
i think in our specific industry in our
specific timing and
we were very lucky to to experience that
uh
but we just felt on every part so far
that
getting this external funding isn't
going to
limit our growth nevertheless it's
it's definitely something that maybe at
a certain point will be interesting
uh but luckily enough we didn't need it
so far
i think that as someone who's never
experienced this
i can very without without a lot of
confidence say that
it sounds like it takes a lot of
confidence to go that route
in a world where pr is all about
fundraising
and your worth is dictated by your
valuation
which can't really be decided unless
you've
fundraised uh that's that's a very brave
brave route to go and i think that it
it exceeds on the quality of what ron
forest is doing today
and i think that by looking at the
problem that you're solving the way that
you're solving it the thought process
that you have
leading the company it makes perfect
sense to me why you chose that very
intentional route
because it's it takes a lot of
intentionality to not
go on the on the ordinary fundraising
round
alon i i really want to thank you for
the time i you want to say something
right
yeah so one comment just because i think
you've you touched a really important
point i think one of
the challenges we had is because in our
industry
your your valuation and announcing
grounds
it's such a you know a milestone for
every startup
and we want to obviously get the top
talent talent to join run for us right
and and i think that's a discussion we
had a lot of time with with the talent
that is used to in asking okay what's
your value what was your valuation in
the last round right
and i think uh we are able to to
explain to them you should measure a
company by other metrics but
by the revenue by by their growth and
like
think a little bit like an investor and
i think uh
and and i think people understand that
we were able to drive the most amazing
talent and we have uh the most amazing
team
and i think they they really understand
uh the important uh
the important thing and the and the
opportunity of the company and also the
the benefit of not having
uh investor and the flexibility that it
gives you
to continue growing the way you think is
right i mean it's it's literally just
allowing you to focus more right it's
focusing if if the ordinary
startup has to focus on a few key
pillars one of the main ones is
fundraising you know
a lot of ceos are saying fundraising is
a full-time job when you
when you raise your seed bye bye for
three months i'm gonna
i'm fundraising don't talk to me right
when you're raising seriously about
six months i'm talking to vc's well you
you didn't have to do that you got to
work on the product finding product
market fit
and and obviously the the results show
so along thank you for sharing your time
with me i loved it
i i love your journey and and i can't
wait to continue working with you both
on the investment side but but hopefully
you know in actually
hands-on things and but before we go to
ask you the most important question
which is uh three words you would use to
describe yourself
okay yeah so uh
it's always difficult to answer those
questions about yourself it's a hard
interview
to college who ask those questions
exactly but
uh so the first question is definitely
learning i think i really like to learn
new things and i also try to try new
things
even if i know i'm going to fail because
that's the best way to learn
um the second world i choose is bold
uh i think uh
it took me some time to understand i
just sometimes think about something i'm
like yeah we should do it let's do
partnership with that company in that
company and people in the office are
like
yeah you credit they would never play
along and i'm like why not and
then we make it happen so i don't know
it just uh
just happened and the and the third wall
just to make it a bit more unique i
would say lazy like
really deep inside i think it's i'm lazy
the the problem is because of of that i
somehow work very hard all the time
to try to find those creative and
original solutions
to to make things work better without
the need of working that out it doesn't
somehow it doesn't work and i think
by the way our solution our our value
for users
is for for lazy users we want to
enlighten the consumer
right we want to help them not not work
that out so i think
relating to your users is always
a good uh characteristic alone
thank you very very much i'll see you on
ben yehuda and
stay safe and stay healthy cool looking
forward see you
on my next dog walk